I would shut down like was so when there
was too much information coming at me
from even from friends suggesting
acupuncture or a nurse suggesting
massage therapy or acupuncture it was
too much and I and I would shut down and
end up with stacks of paper that I
wouldn't look at adding integrative
services to my treatment and then they
also had been able to encourage me and
we had been able to schedule
appointments and look at what was
available from one place that would have
been a game-changer for me hi my name is
Dana Womack I'm an assistant professor
at Oregon Health and Sciences University
we developed a mobile app concept a be
on to simplify access to services and
provide patients with bi-directional
communication with their care team and
others integrative oncology services
really help patients remember the the
wholeness of their life and who they are
and kind of not get trapped in really
just being a cancer patient that they're
of a human being that's going through
the cancer experience in my own cancer
journey and the cancer journey of the
patients that I've worked with I've seen
people seek out integrative oncology
services benefit from those services
I've also seen them struggle with
navigating all of the different options
abbien is designed to provide a central
location for information about a clinics
integrative oncology services such as
acupuncture massage and mindfulness
coaching it'll keep it in a place where
it's easy to reference throughout a
patient's journey it'll simplify signup
enable patients to communicate with
their clinic and with their informal
caregivers and give them update
about how they're doing and feedback
about how integrated services are
helping them tolerate their treatment I
would have loved to be able to access
[Music]
acupuncture massage therapy yoga classes
coming out of my surgeries especially my
mastectomy is the stretching and and
Yoga would have been so beneficial for
me so the inspiration of this app really
lies both in being able to connect
patients more directly with the
integrative oncology services that are
going to help them thrive throughout the
oncology experience but also seeing how
it can serve to deepen the relationship
and communication between patient and
the healthcare team so that the
healthcare team begins to recognize this
broader aspect of their life and their
vibrancy and how they are stepping into
self-care practices and I also think
it's really valuable the way that we are
conceiving that languaging within the
app itself so that the app becomes a
coach of really helping patients
recognize more of what's right with them
rather than just what's wrong with them
we look forward to collaborating with
you to address this unmet need in the
oncology community the physical therapy
piece and the range of motion I know
women who are essentially crippled
because they weren't getting the you
know stretching in the treatment and
it's like
[Music]
you